I would definitely consider myself a
Democrat I - do you think we're gonna do
well on this no no we're gonna suck
[Music]
people in urban America have got to
appreciate that the overwhelming
majority of people who hunt know about
guns and respect guns and are
law-abiding people that's the truth
I feel like it might be him because he's
from Vermont so it's probably a lot more
hunters saying urban is kind of
old-school really old-school is kind of
offensive to which both wouldn't I mean
feel like that's a Hillary statement the
word urban slightly out of touch I think
it was Hillary Bernie I would say I
would create the first ever office of
immigrant Affairs that's not an office
yet talking about creating something
that's never happened before not
worrying about a budget whatsoever but
also going for bureaucracy I feel like
they both say that he keep attacking her
about the kids I feel like that was a
thing in one of the debates
I'm gonna go Hillary that only because
you go a berming I'm gonna say it's a
Hillary thing to say to be like I'm
gonna make another form of government so
I win she's not like I'm gonna end
racism like this guy like I'm gonna make
a department to address this sounds
political
let us wage a moral and political war
against war itself so that we can cut
military spending and use that money for
human needs
I don't think Hillary would be like
let's cut military spending you know we
got a bomb up yeah Oh think so I'm
choosing the burn we read it to me one
more time you owe
[Music]
Wars if it's specific use always Hillary
if it's not specific nurses like let's
just save everyone so you got an
algorithm for this all I do we're asking
the top one and a half percent including
passive income to start paying a little
bit more so that the elderly and
disabled vets in this country can live
with security and dignity as well the
one percent very Bernie but I feel like
him sing for them to pay a little bit
more it's not enough for him it's only
about oh no but they're both pretty old
dude I'm gonna say Hillary Hillary wood
will be with us for another 300 years
yeah I'll follow you but she's specific
she talked about vets I think it's also
Hillary oh yeah no other country can
rally the world to defeat Isis and win
the generational struggle against
radical jihadism Foreign Wars well
Hillary Clinton was our Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton was in the room
like when they were shooting up Osama
bin Laden Hillary point please I feel
like I did horribly a lot of the
statements that I thought the show were
Bernie turned out to be Hillary and vice
versa
I feel like I learned a lot about my
politicians and learned about their
different types of rhetoric
I think what's been tough about this
election is there's just been so much
yelling through the media happening in
so many outrageous things that it's
really hard to cut through all of that
and listen to actually what policies are
being proposed
I think they should just hold hands and
run together y'all should kiss